Guten Morgen Tim.
Also durch die Nacht hören uns die Leute ja eh.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 266.
Ich hätte eigentlich nur eine bessere Antwort gehabt.
Wirklich welche.
Tatenlos durch die Nacht.
Ist der Titel zumindest schon mal klar,
hat das soll sich Leute motiviert fühlen mit musikalischen Talent govori.
Vom 8. September 2018 wir sind wieder da wir waren ein bisschen unterwegs auch gemeinsam teilweise.
Und nicht so viel Worte darüber verlieren wenn man.
Dafür gibt es andere Podcast.
Genau das ist komplett in der Freakshow Catalan Umschau.
Autorundreise Podcast Freakshow.
Genau wird unseren Ausflug nach England Covern oder kriegst du auch mal ein paar drohnenvideos hier während der Sendung machen sonst schon so fleißig bist.
LP von oben oder vielleicht bei der Live-Sendung.
Bei der Live-Sendung.
Richtig gefährlich oder.
Wenn ich fliege schon.
Jaja na gut wir haben volles Programm letzte Woche wollten wir eigentlich aufnehmen aber dann ein wenig ja hat sich.
Verbrennt Hermann brexit gemacht.
Ging ging leider nicht in Britannien war ja aber auch trotzdem was los in Deutschland vor allem im schönen Karl-Marx-Stadt,
den Witz bringt es bestimmt alle ne ja.
Proleten aller Länder haben sich vereinigt in Karl-Marx-Stadt,
wurde glaube ich jetzt rauf und runter gekaut brauchen wir,
Detail nicht mehr zu wiederholen es gab einen Angriff auf einen jungen Mann der wurde im Rahmen dieses Angriffs getötet
bitte sagen Mord oder Totschlag wird dann halt ein Gericht klären,
und die Personen oder Person nennen die ihn angegriffen und getötet haben waren Ausländer das hat,
in
Die die jetzt vermutet werden.
Die mutmaßlichen Täter sind,
Mutter hat sich Ausländer das hat Jan.
Dazu geführt dass man in Chemnitz in tiefer Trauer Warum den getöteten Daniel H der sächsische Verfassungsschutz warnte vorher schon die Polizei das ist bei einer
das ist bei dieser
bei diesem Trauermarsch zu einer Teilnehmerzahl im unteren bis mittleren vierstelligen Bereich zu erwarten sein und es dann können Sie davon ausgehen dass Angriffe von rechts
extremen auf dem politischen Gegner die Polizei sowie auf neuralgischer
lichkeiten Viva Kampf groß und Flüchtlingsunterkünfte komme könne kommen könnte.
Kam aber dann natürlich ganz anders dieser Trauermarsch war von tiefer Trauer
geprägt die dort vertretenen Adolf Hitler Hooligans trugen vor lauter Trauer den Hitlergruß auf Halbmast und die Hose gleich dazu,
es wurden Videos im weiteren Verlauf veröffentlicht wo Menschen,
weggejagt wurden es entfachte sich dann in der Öffentlichkeit im weiteren Verlauf einer
Diskussion darüber wie weit man jemanden wegjagen muss damit man von einer Hetzjagd sprechen kann es entwickelt sich natürlich auch online Verschwörungstheorien darüber dass,
die Menschen die da weggejagt wurden die natürlich andere hautfarben hatten dass sie natürlich.
Inhalieren totes verachtende Mut diese dort versammelten Trauer tragenden provoziert haben,
und alles einfach nur das was man glaube ich eine riesige shitshow,
nennt wollen wir glaube also muss man glaube ich gar nicht großartig bewerten das ist ein trauriger Moment gewesen.
Für wahrscheinlich alle die da waren,
die Familie des Getöteten hat wenn ich mich recht entsinne ihr oder zumindest die Freunde und Familie des Getöteten haben ihr Befremden über diese Fremdenfeindlichkeit ausgedrückt.
Die Jagdszenen die dann da übermittelt wurden haben jetzt auch nicht dazu beigetragen dass man sich.
Besonders sicher noch fühlt in Karl-Marx-Stadt und wir haben eine erneute.
Ausführliche Debatte in Deutschland über Fremdenfeindlichkeit den,
Schulterschluss der AFD mit diesen Gruppierungen mit diesen extremistischen Gruppierungen offenbaren ganz andere Auffassung auf einer von Trauer ja also.
Sehr sehr betroffen gewesen sein die Adolf Hitler Hooligans ja also.
Vor allem ich meine der Deck tötete ist ja selber kubanischer,
bis zur Hälfte kubanischer Abstammung gewesen ist das richtig gehört habe.
Der war nicht der war nicht rein deutsch.
Das klappt doch gut ich nun wirklich kein Mensch dass ihr auf die hier irgendwie irgendeine Anteilnahme zelebriert,
nein im Gegenteil hier ist einfach auf die Gelegenheit gewartet worden irgendetwas zum Anlass zu nehmen wo man wieder mal die Hetze gegen die andersartigen ausleben kann und hat vor allem versucht,
maximal aufzutreten maximal über die Stränge zu schlagen um das System zu testen wie es denn so reagiert und wie viel Widerstand gegen das was diese Gruppen bereit sind zu tun es gibt,
das Ergebnis ist eigentlich kein Polizeistaat rum.
Mama sich mal anschaut wie so eine durchschnittliche Straßenblockade von,
nimm Dich linken Gruppierung mit einem Überangebot von Polizei beantwortet wird.
Wenn ich nur zur Durchführung sogar dann auch im Vorfeld dessen dann fragt man sich halt wirklich,
wie ist in Eidelstedt um die Polizei und die mit ihr verbundenen Behörden warum sie denn an dieser Stelle nicht in der Lage ist hier die entsprechende Reaktion zu zeigen wer hier kannst nur eine Reaktion geben,
da muss einfach maximal ging gehalten werden.
Aber natürlich dann noch so schöne weitere Situationen sie den Bürger in Wut Abgeordneten Jan Timke.
Der auf Facebook einen Haftbefehl veröffentlicht hat der quasi nach dem Tod des 35-Jährigen in Chemnitz.
Erlassen wurde durch die.
Chemnitzer durch die Bremer Moment die Bremer Staatsanwaltschaft geht demnach weil das ja auch im Bremer Abgeordnete ist als der.
Also die wert,
von der Staatsanwaltschaft ein Haftbefehl erlassen nach dem Tod der nach diesem Totschlag oder Mord was jetzt klären ist.
Und diesen Haftbefehl hat jetzt dieser Bremer Abgeordnete veröffentlicht
das ist aber rechtswidrig kannst dich irgendwie auf Facebook Haftbefehle veröffentlich dass er interne Dokumente der Staatsanwaltschaft das heißt die Chemnitzer Staatsanwaltschaft hat offenbar ein Leck,
zu irgendwelchen Wutbürger Abgeordneten.
Also der da bräuchte man echt mal jemanden der den Sumpf sonst trocken trocken legt ne Sohn Trump oder so wait,
das heißt das sind wirklich das sind alles Vorgänge die sind äußerst äußerst beunruhigend und die ergeben ein echt und schönes Bild,
wir wollen es aber heute viel mehr damit auseinandersetzen also wir gehen davon aus dass,
Tabea weht hier irgendwie zuhört und irgendwie ja aber jetzt noch sagt der sollte sich den Rest der Sendung gar nicht erst anhören weil,
jetzt kommt erstmal so ein richtiges Jahr aber für euch liebe Freunde.
Die Reaktionen darauf sind tatsächlich das was ich noch sehr sehr viel schlimmer finde dass du in Chemnitz irgendwelche Justizbeamten hast die.
Die Haftbefehle an irgendwelche rechtsnationalen Abgeordneten liegen,
ist noch nicht mal mehr überraschend so tragisch das auch ist dass du in sachsen.de Polizei hast die im Zweifelsfall zu,
nennenswerten Teil mit den,
Leuten die da diesen Todesfall für ihre politischen Ziele missbrauchen hegen ist auch,
Tages aber nicht neu.
Dass du aber dann einen Innenminister in Deutschland hast der infolgedessen irgendwie in die Öffentlichkeit tritt und sagt,
die Mutter aller Probleme sei aber jetzt hier die Migration und man sollte man nicht vergessen dass die Ausländer an daran schuld sind.
Das ein echtes Problem und dann tritt auch noch der Präsident des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz,
hört sich immer die Frage ne also jetzt gibt es Videos wie diese rechtsnationalen Adolf Hitler Hooligan Demonstranten und,
besorgten Bürger in Chemnitz halt irgendwie Jagd auf Menschen machen,
die sagt Jagd Frage ist ab wie viel Meter ist Jagd ich würde sagen wenn als wenn du jemand dazu bringst wegzurennen kann man schon von Jagd reden,
traditionelle rhetorische sagen solange es keine Treibjagd mit Hunden ist für ne da da da da fare über die Begriffe diskutieren oder dürfen die dann über die Begriffe diskutieren,
und jetzt haben wir natürlich den Verfassungsschutz Präsidenten für das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz nicht zu verwechseln mit dem sächsischen Verfassungsschutz der sächsische Verfassungsschutz ja wo man jetzt sei mal vorsichtig schätzen würde das der,
jetzt nicht unbedingt linksgrünversifft ist,
vorsichtig geschätzt ja hat davor gewarnt dass es da zu solchen Situationen kommen könnten und jetzt tauchen diese Videos auf dem Video, gleich noch mal und jetzt hast du den Präsident des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz in Maßen.
Der muss natürlich jetzt dementieren warum er weiß im Zweifelsfall seine Leute warten,
klar also.
Gib mir der Bild-Zeitung der Präsident des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz,
gibt der Bild-Zeitung ein Interview und sagt er hätte er habe Hinweise dass es sich dabei um eine um eine Fälschung handelt bei diesem Video,
die gezielt platziert wurden von dem Ort an dem deutschen abzulenken.
Es gibt dann jetzt Untersuchungen z.b. hier Stern jetzt soll ich mal dass das Sturmgeschütz des Boulevards ja geht's hin.
Die kann sich in dem Thema auch aus ich habe noch Schulden in den Tagebüchern alles nachgelesen.
Das Sturmgeschütz des Boulevards.
Geht hin und untersucht diese Video dieses Video und sagt z.b. sehr elegant eigentlich mal sagt naja Tageszeit,
stimmt so von wieder Schatten fällt sannauer z.b. da ist ein werbe,
Plakat für eine bestimmte Veranstaltung die erst seit dann und dann in dieser Stadt stattfindet und Werbeplakaten ja auch nicht so lange,
der Ort
deckt sich mit den Berichten inzwischen hat auch der Mensch der gejagt wurde Anzeige erstattet die Gunst ich glaube irgendwie 100 noch was Leute auch die in welche Anzeigen wegen Angriffen wohl in Chemnitz erstattet haben also da war richtig Rambazamba,
und der Chef des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz zweifelsohne irgendeine irgendeinen Beweis irgendein billig oder sonstiges zu nennen in der Öffentlichkeit in der in der Bild-Zeitung,
an der Echtheit dieses Videos und du fragst Dich wirklich was hat er denn.
Das nicht die Echtheit des Video soll er meinte ja auch es habe ja keine Hetzjagd and also es gebe gar keine.
Perca nerzjacken geben das Video muss eine Fälschung sein.
Ja also das genau so wäre das gewesen ist in welcher Form diese Fälschung stattgefunden haben soll keine Information.
Wenn gehen wir mal davon aus dass es so wäre,
ja dann ist der sich die Frage warum geht der nicht zum Seehofer oder zu Merkel.
Hurts also Bundeskanzleramt Geheimnis Koordinate oder sonst was und sagt ey.
Kraftech Faktencheck views ja wir müssen was dagegen unternehmen was macht der Typ bei der Bild Zeit hinein was man irgendjemand bei der Bild-Zeitung aber dann noch ausgerechnet der.
Oder dem Moment.
In dem Moment so also entweder liegt er die Beweise vor und dann ist gut und zwar den zuständigen Stellen,
oder der kann sich jetzt mal gepflegt zurückziehen,
na ja wer wer dafür verantwortlich sein quasi Vorgesetzter Dienstherr oder seine Dienstaufsicht ist natürlich Innenminister Seehofer das passt natürlich auch wieder wie Arsch auf Auge wie man so schön sagt.
Ja aber der ist beschäftigt der ist im freien Wettbewerb.
Bitte steht im freien Wettbewerb mit Donald Trump mit weniger Anwesenheit also nimmt er überhaupt dann irgendetwas Teil also nimmt irgendwie an Sitzung nicht Teil der tut halt auch im Wesentlichen alles gar nichts,
außer irgendwie seine eigenen merkwürdige Agenda.
Also er am im Mai hat Angela Merkel schon Seehofer ihr Vertrauen ausgesprochen es wäre jetzt an der Zeit dem auch endlich mal Taten folgen zu lassen.
Ja genau das kann sie nicht machen.
Weiß gerade also wie wem,
wie kannst du der Verfassung mehr Schaden als solches Misstrauen zu verbreiten wie kannst du deinen die Unfähigkeit deine Arbeit,
auszuüben besser unter Beweis stellen als als derjenige der der Verfassungsschutz ist der Präsident des Verfassungsschutzes ja als da irgendwelche wirren Spekulationen.
In der Bild-Zeitung zu euch in der Bild-Zeitung zu äußern ohne einen Beleg dafür zu liefern weil ich fensterwunder von mir aus also was er hat für äußerst unwahrscheinlich dass dieses Video gefälscht ist,
könnte natürlich sein dass es das wäre aber dann lieber ja Maße Sache einmal auf und und tue deine gottgegebene Arbeit und liefert die Beweise dafür haben wir das,
wenn dieses Video jetzt tatsächlich hier die die die die Menschheit in Aufruhr,
versetzt dann Weite deines Amtes und gib uns die gib uns die Belege sieht aber.
Suche gib der Region die Beläge.
Gibt genau gib der Regierung und überlege sieht aber im überhaupt nicht danach aus dass das der Fall ist.
Das war mal das Geheimdienst.
Völlig.
Seit wann geben Geheimdienste Interviews im Boulevard Zeit.
Apropos Geheimdienst genau das mit dem geheim nimmt dermaßen ja normalerweise ernst,
als es nämlich Berichte der Medien gab Anfang 2017 dass es im Umfeld des Attentäters Anis Amri ein V-Mann des Verfassungsschutzes gegeben hat.
Da hat dermaßen denen anwaltliche Korrektur bitten schicken lassen.
Auch sehr schön ja das heißt unser Verfassungsschutz geht irgendwie gegen die freie Berichterstattung in der Presse vor.
Spielt irgendwie da in der Bild-Zeitung sich auf es ist wirklich wirklich nicht mehr haltbare Zustände das Video übrigens veröffentlicht von einem,
von einer Gruppe
Vodafone einem Account mit dem Namen Antifa Zeckenbiss der zu dem der seine Pressemitteilung dazu rausgegeben hat und sagt zum Video Menschenjagd in Chemnitz.
Das Video wurde weder manipuliert geschnitten noch gekürzt,
das Video ist ein Netzfund es wurde von uns am 26.08 2018 einer patriotischen Gruppe gefunden vor auch Hetze gegen Flüchtlinge betrieben worden ist wer es aufgenommen hat wissen wir nicht es wurde von uns so veröffentlicht,
die wir es gefunden haben vermutlich wurde das ja irgendwie gefilmt von einer,
von einer jungen Dame die dann auch noch irgendwie zu ihrer männlichen Begleiter sagt Hase du bleibst hier du bleibst hier dürfte nicht mitmachen.
Ja hätte ich hatte egal das Video gesehen habe dass das Band aus dem linken Kulturkreis war ich glaube sie hätten sich in dem Moment auch nicht sonderlich sicher.
Also dieser Account Antifa Zeckenbiss hat ein hat einen Account Service Logo mit einem das Antifa Logo mit einem roten und mit einem schwarzen Laptop.
Man könnte also darüber philosophieren wir die vielleicht an welche Informationen gekommen sind vielleicht ist es sogar geheim.
Der ermittelt.
Immerhin einer der nicht mit dem Bild redet,
ja das ist alles extrem beunruhigend ich muss sagen zur kurzen also sollte das aus eurem Kurzzeitgedächtnis schon wieder verschwunden sein das ist derselbe Herr Maaßen der noch vor kurzem in der Öffentlichkeit stand weil er,
laut Bericht dieser Aussteigerin aus der AFD mit der AFD gesprochen hat,
der AFD Hinweise darauf gegeben hat wie sich den Verhalten kann um einer Beobachtung durch den Verfassungsschutz zu entgehen und der auch gesagt haben soll das halt diesen ganzen Projekt ja ich weiß es nicht mal genau wie die formuliere.
Wohlgesinnt ist wohlgesonnen.
Wohlgesonnen sein
das scheint ganz gut hier zu passen wenn man sich das anschaut ist ein bisschen schwierig jetzt hier Schlüssel zu ziehen aber es drängt sich natürlich extrem
der Blick auf dass wir es hier mit einem Verfassungsschutz zu tun haben,
dessen Chef vielleicht selber die AFD wählt oder mindestens das irgendwie eigentlich ganz geil findet dass Sie da sind.
Indessen Behörde über Jahre schon immer früher auch sehr alles nichts Neues,
die rechtsradikale Szene angeblich infiltriert wird durch V-Leute de facto sind das einfach Leute die deren Präsenz als ich schon mein Problem ist nicht nur weil man den Verdacht haben muss,
das hier schlicht und ergreifend die rechte Szene auch finanziert wird,
das hier vielleicht Informationen gewonnen werden aber dass man eher so kontrollierte Begleitung ausübt und nicht so sehr daran interessiert ist diese Szene wirklich,
und holt uns ja außer Gefecht zu setzen,
bist ja vielleicht ganz angemessen wäre wenn man die Verfassung schützen will wo drin steht das faschistische Bestrebungen nicht stattzufinden haben.
Ja und die dann halt immer wenn es um sowas wie NPD-Verbot kommt sehr dem Gesetz auch Probleme macht,
gerade durch diese V-Leute und die Verstrickung in den nsips die Geschichte ist endlos geht seit Jahrzehnten,
und wird immer schlimmer und mittlerweile wirkendes absolut.
Bei dem also in das all das NPD-Verbotsverfahren ist er schon länger her bzw gleich zwei ich mich nicht täusche.
Ja das erste ist halt deswegen gescheitert wegen dieser RV Lloyd.
Weil die ungefähr jeder 7 jeder siebte Funktionsträger bei der NPD stand bei denen auf der Gehaltsliste,
in den die gesamte Situation den gesamten Bereich nsu-komplex braucht man gar nicht erst zu öffnen wo auch dann verschiedene Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz mit drin,
stecken haben die aktenschredder affair.de erfahrene nachdem der NSU
aufgeflogen ist es ja mehr über jetzt X oder über ein Jahrzehnt unentdeckt,
gemordet obwohl eigentlich vielen bekannt war dass es diesen fsuk habe das ist also wirklich eine.
Eine Katastrophe ehrlich gesagt das ist nicht mehr witzig wenn dein Inlandsgeheimdienst und dein Innenminister sehr sehr klar an einem.
Also ihre Neutralität sehr sehr eindeutig verloren haben.
Noch alarmierender finde ich wenn man dann in Minister hat den das offensichtlich überhaupt nicht zu kratzen Schal.
Und der Bundeskanzlerin die das nicht kratzt dass es den Innenminister nicht.
Wir könnten natürlich ich habe tatsächlich gestern längere Zeit gesucht wer alles,
die Möglichkeit hätte den den Maßen zu entlasten also zu entlassen
wenn ich das richtig sehe wird der vom Bundesministerium des Innenminister ernannt aber es war so dass ich das Kabinett auf die Personalie geeinigt hat
und ich habe tatsächlich irgendwie versucht so dicke den Gesetzestext zu finden wo steht sie wird man den los,
habe den aber nicht direkt gefunden ich vermute die sinnvolle Möglichkeit wäre dass man den Seehofer kickt,
unten vernünftige Innenminister installiert und der dann einen neuen Chef für das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz dann hast du aber wahrscheinlich innerhalb eines halben Jahres den Maßen irgendwo bei der AFD hängen.
Und dann wird er
wieso ein Verschwörungstheoretiker die ganzen Scheiß in die Weltraum und alle sagen ja der Verfassungsschutz der hat das ja genau gesehen der weiß das ja alles der kann dadurch drüber reden den man muss man einfach jeden Scheiß glauben den er redet weil der natürlich unter
Geheimhaltungspflichten liegt das heißt wenn er sagt es gibt Hinweise dann ist ja ganz klar warum der das nicht mit irgendetwas belegen muss ist ja geheim.
Ja da können wir uns jetzt echt noch mal warm anziehen bis dir sicher dass sie hier unsere Staatsbürgerschaft noch haben willst hin.
Naja so als Option ich sammle jetzt einfach so viele wie ich kann damit ich dann mit Salz Fall immer die ja die passende Kollekte mal genau dann mal.
Wieso Pokémon ohne Garde Collection Collection Moll oder wer Pokémon ein Portal zum nächsten Rennen und überall findest beraten.
Also bei den ganzen Ereigniskarten ist immer ganz gut wenn man möglichst viele Optionen.
Nee ist nicht schön also.
Das sind echt keine guten Nachrichten und jetzt kann man eigentlich nur daran erinnern.
Man muss eigentlich auch schon davon ausgehen dass ich dieses Land in der Hinsicht einfach schon im unterwandert and Zustand.
Also das ist jetzt nicht so nur so eine Kritik an einzelnen Personen sollen die Tatsache dass das stattfinden kann zeugt einfach von einer größeren etablierten Struktur deren Größe wir,
wahrscheinlich gar nicht absehen können also ich bin wirklich kein Freund von Verschwörungstheorien als Miss von schlecht unter fütterten,
nur ist es offensichtlich dass hier keine Automatismen greifen die wünschenswert werden und das sollte einmal.
Ja
es gibt natürlich auch viele strukturelle Gründe die tatsächlich dazu führen dass du Vene irgendwie bei der Polizei oder so tätig bist du auch ein
bestimmten gewählt Gesellschaft Ausschnitt siehst der dich weniger liberal und mehr.
Tja feindlich gegenüber Freiheiten werden lässt das ist Teil der großen Herausforderungen die mit solchen Aufgaben kommt natürlich hast du,
bei der Polizei wie überall sonst auch Menschen die ihren Aufgaben und ihren Herausforderung nicht gewachsen sind insofern ist es auch nicht verwunderlich dass du,
von einer derartigen Tendenz insbesondere bei diesen Behörden,
ausgehen muss aus diesem Grunde glaube ich das sieht man jetzt sehr klar dass wir in den nächsten Jahren uns sehr bemühen müssen.
Demokratische,
Werte in diesem Land zu retten und zu erhalten dazu gehört selbstverständlich auch bevor wir jetzt wieder irgendwelche Spinner in den Kommentaren haben dass man Probleme die in einem Land existieren,
nicht negiert und diese Probleme auch angeht mit Kompetenz.
Und Willen zur Lösung.
Aber es sollte sich dabei eben auch um Probleme handeln die tatsächlich existieren und für sowas braucht man eine vernünftige Regierung Vernunft orientierte Regierung und nicht so.
Keiner Form kann man da ein Personal gebrauchen sie Seehofer und Maßen die ganz offensichtlich nicht daran interessiert sind in diesen Zeiten besonnen zu reagieren,
wenn der seine Regierung nicht mehr besonnen agiert dann befindest du dich tatsächlich in einer Krise.
Nicht nur besonnen reagiert sein vorallem auch aktiv reagiert meine Mama jetzt schon die,
die Polizei und die Gewaltentrennung ca haben dann ist es halt auch einfach erforderlich dass man gegen solche Mops,
die vorgeht und dieser Mangel an Widerstand der hier geleistet wird von staatlicher Seite den finde ich halt in dem Zusammenhang auch besonders.
Dann noch kurz wir sollten erwähnen dieses Konzert wir sind mehr großes Ding irgendwie Toten Hosen feine Sahne Fischfilet,
Casper Kraftklub und noch so jemand in noch mehrere Bands der Namen ich mir nicht merken konnte weil ich sie nicht kannte,
es gab da eben auch eine relativ starke Positionierung der Zivilgesellschaft die natürlich,
positiv zu bewerten ist auf der man sich aber eben nicht ausruhen darf weil wenn also Chemnitz ist eine Stadt mit einer knappen viertel Millionen Einwohner wenn du da ein Konzert machst mit 65000 Leuten und irgendwie mehreren top
Bands in Deutschland und die Leute kommen von überall her.
Dann sind 65000 eben auch nicht die krasseste Zahl,
aber wenn dann andererseits Leute an die Öffentlichkeit gehen und das als Provokation bezeichnen ja stehen harte Zeiten bevor habe ich den Eindruck und ich möchte mit Dante schließen.
Der heißeste Platz der Hölle ist für jene bestimmt die in Zeiten der Krise neutral bleiben.
Na aber wäre das Internet das hilft sicherlich total dabei oder.
Das Internet das Internet haben wir ja gebaut damit wir uns informieren können und.
Alle kühler werden miteinander kommunizieren können und ich hänge dieser dieser Utopia immer noch an.
Brauch ich auch.
Also ich wach morgens auf ne und dann denke ich mir aber erstmal so ein bisschen in die Welt schauen,
und dann nehme ich mir einen device und schaue in die Welt und dann zittert gelaufen,
in den USA und gab es jetzt eine.
Kongress Anhörung meria mehrerer der großen Social Media Giganten also geladen waren Facebook Twitter Google.
Google hat glaube ich gesagt ja wir schicken oder eine ein eine einer war nicht da,
einer hat gesagt wir schicken euch irgendwie hier jemand aus der vierten Reihe und hat der Kongress gesagt nee nee die haben ja den CEO vorgeladen oder sowas sagt wir wollen schon jemand mit dem C im Namen wir wollen jemand der Verantwortung trägt er da gabs also noch irgendwelche Diskussionen das ist jetzt eine Anhörung oder unterhalten die sich unterhalten
übern im Prinzip die Tendenzen der sozialen Medien die,
Menschen nicht näher zu bringen sondern auseinander zu bringen ja genau also Google war nicht da weil Google gesagt hat wir schicken euch ein wir schicken euch in die Praktikantin oder sowas.
Diese Debatte wird als jetzt in den USA geführte die New York Times hat er jetzt gerade sehr schöne Forschungen noch mal,
produziert die sich auch mit Deutschland mit diesen deutschen Situation auseinandersetzen wohne mich jemand gesagt hat a-ha.
Das Interesse an Chemnitz wächst ja wir schauen mal welche welche such bei welchem Videos lande ich eigentlich wenn ich den Suchbegriff Chemnitz bei
google eingebe und da hat sich jemand einfach an die an die Apps von Google gehängt und hat dann gesagt okay suche nach Chemnitz ok welche Videos kriege ich
dann die Videos genommen welche Videos werden mir dann empfohlen ja und hat dann quasi einen Baum gebaut und hat dann wenn du das machst dann wenn strukturiert einfach alles durch gehst dann siehst du ja quasi den Baum der Empfehlungen
Poulenc YouTube dich hin prinzipiell würdest du ja erwarten wenn die Empfehlungen die youtube.de gibt keine politische,
Tendenz haben hätten dann würdest du ihr wie erwarten dass du keine Ahnung,
Videos und Interpretationen in verschiedenen politischen Dimensionen und Couleur and bekommen würde es also sowohl irgendwelche rechtsgerichtete Verschwörungstheoretiker als auch,
übersetze ich informierte Menschen die sie mit dem Phänomen auseinandersetzen als auch.
Wie nennt man das jetzt neuerdings wenn man nicht Faschist ist linksextrem genau also linksextreme alles was nicht falsch ist ist ist ja Antifa und Antifa ist ja auch Faschist ist ja linksextrem so ist ja unfair jetzt die Wahrnehmung,
muss man jetzt auch sich erstmal dran gewöhnen dass man jetzt plötzlich wenn man sich wenn man die Adolf Hitler Hooligans kritisch beäugt.
Nun am linksextremen Rand der Gesellschaft findet das war eine Zeitlang anders das sind ja ganz anders Jessica Sanders geprägt wurden.
Die kommen ja aus der Konterrevolution 68 und so jetzt hast du der hatte dann festgestellt dass er ganz klar.
Im Prinzip diese Video also YouTube immer in Richtung der Extremisten lenkt
wer hat das jetzt auch mal empirisch an diesem Beispiel wiedergefunden haben das Thema ja hier auch schon öfter besprochen dass das eine,
im Zweifelsfall eine Folge dessen ist dass diese Netzwerke diese Seiten seit Facebook-Seite ist YouTube die leben ja davon dass man auf der Seite bleibt das Primärziel von YouTube ist,
dass du das nächste Youtube-Video guckst und damit du das nicht so Youtube-Video guckst muss das eben krasser sein als das was du davor gesehen hast und was ist krasser als.
Tagesschau was ist krasser als was weiß ich irgendwelche Handyvideos krasser ist in vollkommener durchgeknallter rechter der dir dann noch ihre Theorie dazu erzählt ja und diese diese besorgten
Trauernden in Chemnitz die die dann da irgendwie rumschreien die.
Bernd provoziert worden in in ihrer Trauer.
Darüber würde sich also hier jetzt eh vor dem US-Kongress unterhalten,
ins weiterhin aber natürlich auch was die USA ja immer noch beschäftigt Einflussnahme auf die US-Politik aus dem Ausland na also im Prinzip wie sich,
nicht die sich ausländische Kräfte dieser sozialen Medien bemächtigen oben in irgendeiner Form auf die,
US-Politik einzuwirken an diese am Rande dieses Phänomen ist haben wir dann natürlich auch unseren lieben Freund Alex Jones,
Washington gehabt er Erektion ist dann dort rumgerannt und das konntest du dir also das kann man sich also kann man sich das angucken oder nicht eigentlich muss man sich mal angucken,
aber du kriegst wirklich also ich habe ich habe echt diesen Rubio wirklich bewundert,
dass der dir nicht einfach in die Fresse gehaut hat der hatte also Marco Rubio wurde da irgendwie interviewt von.
Also republikanischer Politiker aus Florida.
Ich weiß gar nicht genau wo Florida oder wo der genau herkommt,
müsste ich wissen ja ne der wurde da irgendwie interviewt und also jemand hat versucht ihn zu interviewen.
Dann ist er wieder dazwischen.
Was heißt wieder dazwischen gesprochen der ist ja ein Föhn dieser dieser dieser alexion ist ein Föhn der der daneben stand und ihn beschimpft hat
ja so in dieser Rubio steht da hinten versottet irgendwie so außerdem ist also in einer Engelsgeduld schafft er das auch und sagt er dir wieso,
Hi junge Landwirtin erklärt wer das ist wenn er sagt er irgendwie so
ey Alter du lass dich vermisse in Ruhe you gonna get yourself arrested und.
Warte warte warte Marco Rubio tut so als wisse er nicht mehr Alex Jones ist was nimmt die doch keiner ab.
Das Video nicht gesehen.
Ich habe das Video noch nicht gesehen.
Okay müsste anschauen aber also ist ja auch völlig egal ob er den kennt oder nicht aber der,
sag dann also er ignoriert ihn sehr schön und dann sagt er irgendwann du wirst ja gleich verhaftet ich kümmere mich da sonst selbst drum
ja und dann dann schreit der Schrei der Erektionsdauer im Grunde hat mir gedroht mit Gewalt er hat gesagt er kümmert sich um mich kümmert sich um mich das eine Drohung,
wirklich du kriegst Fieber wenn du dann guckst weil dein weil weil du irgendwie merkst wie das irgendwann in deinen Körper gerade angegriffen wird und schaden,
nimmt außerdem hat er sich dann den CNN Reporter Oliver Darcy,
vorgenommen und den auch irgendwie einer Hasstirade unterzogen wie auch jeden sollte es irgendwelchen Frauen begegnet dir in die lang gelaufen sind die hatte dann natürlich sofort für,
für ihn bi-sexuell und ziemlich gehalten und hat die dann da irgendwie beschimpft Katastrophe also wirklich wo man sagt so.
Der braucht Hilfe und.
Braucht er braucht Hilfe er auch hin.
Office Hilfe und dann hat er diesen diesen Oliver Darcy beschimpft also CNN Reporter,
kannst du dir auf Info Rost infowars.com die Seite die feiert das sogar ne viennent Reporter Oliver Darcy spirit
here broken as I was confronted confronted,
Alex Jones ja sein sein sein sein Esprit seine Ausstrahlung sein ganzer Geist war gebrochen als Alex Jones ihm Sachen an den Kopf warf wie
du bist antiamerikanisch,
du bist ein Feigling gegen die freie Rede.
Empirische smiling like a Possum that crawled out of the rear end of the Dead cow,
ja okay dann sagt er schaut euch diese Augen an das sind die Augen einer Ratte,
einen Kredit kriminellen von CNN und wirklich einfach nur wirklich skurriler scheiß du bist das Äquivalent der Hitlerjugend
und diese diese infowars die zeigen dass noch als in einem eigenen Artikel als Teil 1 Jahr als Highlights.
Einfach nur die Beleidigung aufgezählt.
Übungen die dieser du bist tatsächlich ein Soziopath und du findest es witzig also es ist wirklich der ist unfassbar.
Bitte unfassbar was ist unfassbar dasss das Wappen Publikum findet.
Ohne dich feiern das noch wie dieser offensichtlich echt nicht mehr ganz offen stand,
sich befindende LX Fenster durch dieses durch 70 durch Washington reden und eben größtenteils bedacht wird so übrigens auch von diesem,
von diesen CNN Reporter der halt auch größtenteils 1800 wird,
da steht und wie auch den General skydesign weiß was dieser Mann ihr gerade macht Ergebnis Twitter.
Wirft erektions raus.
Und sagt er soll hier wir hatten ja gesagt wir konnten den bisher nicht rauswerfen weil er nicht gegen unsere Guidelines verstoßen hat aber,
dass er dieses Video eben auf periscope und auf Twitter veröffentlicht hatte permanently banned bei mehrmals geliefert und Apple,
jetzt auch die App von dem Typen und jetzt muss man auch echt Sachen nachdem was hätte Hack gemacht hat.
Keine Ausreden mehr.
Gibt's keine Ausreden mehr ich bleibe bei meiner Festlegung dass der Typ da am Ende im Prinzip nur,
Großkapital ziehen wird sowohl irgendwelche,
Trump Verschwörungstheorien als auch diese Lektion Verschwörungstheorien werden davon profitieren von egal was dieser Typ tut,
und vielleicht fragen sich auch einige warum wir dieses Thema hier so ausführlich besprechen ehrlich gesagt weil ich Sorge habe dass wir eine derartige.
Einen derartigen Untergang der politischen Kultur auch erleben könnten,
und wir sind ja auch schon dabei wir sind halt noch nicht dort angelangt dass wir solche Clowns durchs Bild hinten haben aber es wird nicht mehr lange dauern bis sie sich,
formieren oder wahrscheinlich gibt die schon lange und die müssen jetzt nur noch durch die YouTube Algorithmen genug subscriber finden.
Ich meine die die die die ersten Clowns haben wir ja nun schon im Bundestag sitzen ne also ich meine letzten Endes ist ja das was die AFD substantiell
so beizutragen hat und nicht sehr viel anders als was so Typen wie Alex Jones von sich geben das ist alles ohne Substanz und im Prinzip einfach nur
formulierte Hetze,
und die sitzen halt in allen Medien karussellen und wenn die ganze Zeit als talking points und als Gegenpole positioniert ist gerade in diesem obskuren sonntagsinterview runden die
so ein bisschen als deutsches Lagerfeuer im Medienzirkus erhalten ist das ja nun schon über Jahre gangundgäbe gewesen muss ja nur mal die Liste von Themen anschauen die dort behandelt wurden oder,
vorgeblich behandelt wurden,
uns gibt's halt ein ein rechtes Agenda-Setting was hier stattfindet vielleicht nicht unbedingt willentlich,
jetzt von den Medien selbstgesteuert aber sie haben sich diese Falle auch locken lassen.
Also diese Sonntag schaust die schaue ich seit einiger Zeit nicht mehr weil.
Auch nicht aber das ist aber normal aber nur mal das was sozusagen den den den mediendiskurs mit setz,
ja das was da ist ist Thema und das was da als Thema gewählt wird leitet sich eben aus einem wahrgenommenen nach einer wahrgenommenen Themen Priorität ab und die wird eben
Videos auch im Internet schon fast Algorithmus stattfindet auch nach diesem was wird am lautesten geschrien bestimmt,
und auch die Bild-Zeitung die ja zum Höhepunkt der flüchtlingskrise,
immerhin noch der Meinung war wär doch jetzt vielleicht auch mal Opa tun die Massen dadurch zu erreichen dass man jetzt mit dem wir sind doch die guten,
Mädchen mit singt ich war hier Sticker Kampagne und dir helfen und was nicht alles dann aber gemerkt hat dass sie
was ich von Ira Kern Klientel nicht mehr gekauft wird und dann einfach komplett umgeschaltet hat wieder auf Hasspropaganda und jetzt wieder ganz vorne dabei ist,
die Schuld den Ausländern zu geben uns mal ganz einfach zu sagen das ist das Problem.
Halt die die die Medien haben einfach das Problem dass sie eben mit dieser gut ist oder richtig ist was was wohl zahlen erzeugt mit dieser Logik eben den Schreihälsen auf dem Leim geht.
Diese Lösung die wir glaube ich brauchen ist es Menschen in irgendeiner also,
offenbar haben Leute kein Interesse mehr an einer informierten politischen Auseinandersetzung kann auch sehr gut verstehen.
Warum man dieses Interesse nicht mehr hat ja wenn du irgendwie die letzten 20 Jahre Politik in Deutschland begleitet hast zu versagen Politiker.
In Deutschland begleitet hast so wie ich jetzt ungefähr dann verlierst du natürlich auch das Vertrauen in den Laden.
Die Frage ist sollte das dazu führen dass du auch das Vertrauen in.
Die Realität verlierst oder in die Komplexität der der Sachverhalte sollte eigentlich relativ klar sein dass wir nicht unbedingt einfacher,
Lösungen finden bei wir eben auch nicht einfache Probleme haben und das scheint aber den Leuten noch mit abhanden gekommen zu sein.
Und das halte ich für zwei unabhängige erstmal unabhängige Phänomene,
sind sind sie nicht aber sollten sie sein ja dass man sagt okay ich habe den das Vertrauen den politischen Betrieb verloren ihr ich habe,
die ich habe aber jetzt auf einmal eine einfache Lösung ist halt was ganz anderes ja oder oder ich habe es gibt nur noch ein Problem und es gibt die Mutter aller Probleme,
Wie heißt Seehofer und sie schämt sich ganz doll so ne da hast du irgendwie.
Also diese diese Vereinfachungen von von Sachverhalten die echt komplex sind und über diese uns echt mal vernünftig Gedanken machen müssten so,
das findet halt kaum noch statt bzw diejenigen die das tun scheinen immer weniger gehört zu finden,
marklein das also natürlich gibt es,
gerade im independent Medienbereich indem wir uns ja auch bewegen Bestrebungen und so und Bemühungen und da gibt es auch Wachstumsraten ja da wird er gibt's neue Formate,
die jetzt irgendwie scheiße die 266 Folge machen die das versuchen zu bringen,
aber der der die Maine der Mainstream der politischen Debatte geht halt echt in eine in einer sehr sehr,
ungewisse traurige Zukunft.
Ja auf jeden Fall also meine ich ich will ich will so ein bisschen diesen Blick des früher war alles besser widersprechen.
Natürlich hattest du früher auch im politischen Diskurs
Spawner und da gabs irgendwie franz-josef-strauß und ihre K Steinbach und so weiter an die waren schon alle da und das hat ja auch lange Zeit auch ausgebremst dass Dinge besser wurden,
wurden sie dann aber letztlich doch weil es eben am Ende nicht nur jetzt in der medialen Wahrnehmung,
nur die auch geprägt war von Zeitungen RC gab es ja schon dann immer sozusagen so langfristig eine eine Mehrheit für einen ausgeglicheneren Diskurs,
aber das läuft jetzt halt.
Den Sozialismus in seinem Lauf hält weder Ochs noch Esel auf,
hat Obama gerade auch wieder gesagt ne also sinngemäß für alle zwei Schritte die wir nach vorne machen müssen wir noch mal einen zurück machen.
Das ist sicherlich so grundsätzlich habe ich da auch mein Optimismus nicht verloren ganz ehrlich ich denke das.
Alles deiner Hinsicht nur eine Zäsur ist aber doch diese Zäsuren können halt echt Leuten und Gesellschaften und das eben teilweise auch langfristig wir sind dann bisher noch relativ gut bei weggekommen andere Länder weniger.
Dazu muss man nicht erst nach Syrien gucken wo es sozusagen richtig scheiße andere Länder hatten in den letzten 10-20 Jahren nicht unbedingt die beste Phase,
sowaswillichauch sowieso total absolut wie man sich hier in Deutschland überhaupt,
Land hat so wenig Probleme in der Sommer.
Ja das mag sein dass das LAN wenig Probleme hatte kannst aber nicht zur Seite schieben dass es Menschen gibt die Probleme,
und die regen sich dann halt auf und die haben sehr,
dann auch wirklich einfach kein Gehör also wenn wenn du hier in diesem Land irgendwie Harzer bist dann interessiert sich keine Sau für dich,
du bist außerhalb der Gesellschaft fertig niemand hält was von dir niemand hatten,
Interesse an dir und kaum jemand ist ernsthaft,
bemüht an deiner Situation etwas zu ändern weil.
Lange Zeit eine Kultur geprägt wurde die sagt daran bist du jetzt nämlich eben selber schuld und auch ich muss mich regelmäßig daran erinnern.
Das eben nicht alle Menschen in diesem Lande mit gleichen Privilegien,
und außerdem Privilegien übersetzen sich eben Möglichkeiten,
aufgewachsen sind und das ist,
die Mutter aller Probleme Ungleichheit in Zossen.
Das ist notwendig.
Alles staatlich und politische Handeln muss darauf ausgelegt werden die Menschen mit ähnlichen schossen,
auszustatten das heißt Menschen die weniger
privilegiert aufwachsen zu unterstützen ja das heißt bildungsfernen Schichten Möglichkeiten zu geben Bildung zu erlangen das heißt Menschen die,
der Arbeitsmarkt gerade sich nicht wünscht,
zu fördern daran etwas zu ändern das heißt eine Gesellschaft zu bauen in der sich nicht Reichtum und Armut exponentiell vererben.
Bin ich voll bei Dir und deswegen deswegen beklage ich ja auch dass zwei Drittel der Anne Will und wie sie alle heißen Sendung sich dann halt mit
sind die Ausländer an allem Schuld beschäftigen anstatt zu warum verdammt noch mal kriegen Hartz IV la sogar noch das Kindergeld abgezogen.
Er hat also das dass dass uns das ist genau die Kritik nicht.
Weil die uns auf der Tasche hängen im Lebenslauf der Tasche.
Ja klar das ist der Untergang.
Was hat die kriegen 400 € für Noppes.
Jeden jeden Monat.
Jeden Monat pünktlich.
Abzüglich abzüglich Abzug.
Und dann haben die 100 Kinder haben die nämlich.
Klar.
Und die Kinder die kacken bei uns im Flur scheiße, zu was nächsten schön,
wir sind empört über über die Zustände.
Weiß über andere Zustände als über die sich gemeinhin empört.
Wir haben unsere first World problems.
Wir haben ja ja wir haben die Alternative Empörung hier an dieser Stelle müssen zwar auch Wutbürger aber halt ohne Hut.
Die begründe EFD dem Führung für Deutschland.
12. September was ist am 12. September Tim.
IPhones.
Alte Kriege neue iPhone,
Tim Cook kommt und stellt uns die iPhones vor,
Axel Force weiß schon welche Features die nicht haben soll.
Wöhrl.
Denn in dir erinnern uns das Europäische Parlament hatte sich vor einigen Monaten dazu entschieden.
Sein seine Positionierung zur uuuu Wahlrechtsreform noch einmal zu überdenken gab ja den Ausschuss der sich Damon.
Gewidmet hatte und dessen Entscheidungen Vorlage wurde immer abgelehnt sodass jetzt,
die gesamte Angelegenheit noch einmal durchgesetzt wurde und primär interessiert uns ja die beiden oder mehrere verschiedene,
Argumente oder als Teilaspekte dieser dringend notwendigen Copyright Reform insbesondere.
Die Idee der upload-filter und die Idee des Leistungsschutzrechte upload-filter.
In Gesetzesform im Prinzip die Idee zu sagen.
Also im ursprünglichen Vorschlag war es alle also die Plattform haften für alle Urheberrechtsverstöße von Nutzern sie müssen Upload Filter benutzen upload-filter heißt
was hochgeladen wird muss kontrolliert werden.
Ob es die Urheberrechte jemand anderen jemand anderes verletzt und wenn das der Fall ist dann,
darf es gar nicht erst veröffentlicht werden ja also eine,
Abweichung von der aktuellen gängigen Praxis das hochgeladen wird was wolle und wenn es Beschwerden gibt ab in Kenntnis setzen eben die Plattform die es verbreitet in,
der Schuld steht das wieder zu entfernen,
für einige wenige Seiten wie Wikipedia GitHub sollst sollte es dann Ausnahmen geben aber prinzipiell user-generated-content muss einer
Prüfung auf Urheberrechte unterzogen so der ursprüngliche Vorschlag jetzt gibt es mehrere,
Alternativvorschläge die auf der Seite von Julia Reda wie so oft.
Besonders gut dargestellt sind find das echt elegant so eine Tabelle wo drin steht von welcher Fraktion welcher Vorschlag und dann sind der Farben dran wie rot orange gelb grün,
Buddy sortiert nach wie gut die Vorschläge wären.
Wichtig ist natürlich da in Richtung Grün zu kommen um eben ein weiteres.
Ausbremsen von Innovation und Kommunikation durch die Interessen weniger hier zu verhindern ich hatte ja,
in der Sendung und auch in einer Pressemitteilung gleich auf ccc.de mehrmals darauf hingewiesen dass es ein.
Das ist für kleine Unternehmen eben gar nicht möglich ist solche upload-filter zu
bauen was ist die Folge davon du würdest dann eben upload-filter Reiseservice von Google holen ja mit anderen Worten du bist eigentlich ein Konkurrenz von Google,
Liefers alle deine Inhalte vorveröffentlichung aber sowieso schon mal an Google erstens damit Google die schon mal hat,
und zwar ins damit google.de nachher sagt das kannst du nehmen das nicht na also eine völlig völlig irrsinnige Idee diese Upload filtern.
Seite Thema Julian and is ja linksteuer im ursprünglichen Vorschlag,
sogar die kürzesten Ausschnitte aus Nachrichten Artikeln
wie sie beispielsweise in links verwendet werden ne wenn Du hier klickst kommt der Titel und die ersten drei Sätze oder sowas müssen lizenziert werden und zwar von den Verlagen nicht etwa von den Urhebern dieser Artikel nein
von den Rechteverwerter von den Verlagen ein Konzept das nirgendwo,
in diesem großen weiten Internet jemals Erfolg hatte,
weil es eben die Verlage in die Situation bringt dass jene die aussieht linken das dann einfach nicht mehr tun dann brechen die Nutzerzahlen ein.
Ende der Geschichte,
trotzdem wollen sie das jetzt unbedingt einsetzen kpc.de letztens so eine schöne hatten wir auch an den schauen ob so eine schöne Anzeige das hält sie die Verlage sterben weil weil der Google sie verlinkt,
aber wenn er sie nicht verlinkt auch,
deswegen brauchen Sie Geld dafür also diese dicken das Thema mir glaube ich auch hier ausführlich besprochen auch das ist natürlich noch ein wichtiges Thema auch da zum mehrere Vorschläge,
dokumentiert auf der Seite von Julia Rädern und dann,
jetzt nachdem wir den Artikel 3 der sich mit Text und Data Mining auseinandersetzt Data Mining soll nur Forschungseinrichtungen nur zum Zwecke der wissenschaftlichen Forschung genehmigt sein.
Mitgliedstaaten können freiwillig weitere in Gruppen Text Data Mining erlauben wenn dieses Recht nicht explizit vorbehalten ist da gibt's natürlich auch,
eben bessere Vorschläge die in sagen wenn du rechtmäßigen Zugriff hast dann wird er eben auch das Data Mining erlaubt
na mehr zu diesem ganzen Thema eben auf dem verlinkten Artikel wichtig ist da die Abstimmung am 12. stattfindet und jetzt ja erstmal Wochenende ist dann tun die Herren und Damen Politiker ja gar nicht bleiben euch eigentlich nur X unter 11. September.
Da noch mal darauf einzuwirken dass es ein Recht auf remix gibt dass wir Panoramafreiheit für Europa bekommen dass links keine Urheberrechtsverstöße sind sondern Empfehlungen.
Das ist also kein Leistungsschutzrecht gibt auch nicht für Sportveranstalter auch noch ein Thema was jetzt kurzfristig hinzugefügt wurde ne dann könntest du Tim hier demnächst nicht mehr
die schönsten Tore des Wochenendes gucken aber bei du guckst ja immer die Spiele ganz und weiteres ne.
Ja ich meine das ist ja die Faktum findet das ja derzeit oder nicht statt also auf YouTube wird ja gerade sind ganzen sport-clips extrem hinterher.
Ja wenn man sich überlegt was Sportvermarktung schlechte Kosten kann ich das aber natürlich auch verstehen das heißt aber nicht dass ich das gut finde es Sportvermarktung Shrek.
Was was machen wir jetzt hier nicht.
Kann ich mir ja gar nicht leisten machen wir dich auf also Entscheidung am 12.09 pünktlich zum neuen iPhone wenn ihr wollt dass euer iPhone Dauer neues iPhone genauso geil ist dieses alte.
Das ist aber immer noch hochladen können ne.
Das genau dass dass dass das überhaupt noch ewig die haben euch schon die Tastatur genommen,
und das Kabel das Ethernet hat es bei euch genommen und jetzt aller theraplot Funktion als ISO als nächstes hat er dann nur noch viel wieder zum Fernseher.
Wobei vielleicht könnte ich weiß gar nicht ob das mit dem iPhone geht kann man mit dem iPhone DBA verschicken.
Ich,
meist anbiya teilnehmen ich habe da so meine Zweifel.
Wie lange hat aber immerhin Bär ist am 3. September wieder an den Start gegangen.
Besondere elektronische anwaltspostfach um das mal ausgesprochen zu haben.
Nici Bär schöne Grüße an Beate weil die ganze Zeit online,
wir haben darüber insbesondere gesprochen in lnt welche Sendung war es ich such's noch mal raus make Dollar Dollar Dollar fast np242 vom 5. Februar.
War nicht teuer das war paragraph.
MAC Paragraph aber feuerfass.
Aber nicht aussprechen aber lass dich lustig.
Lasse ich lustig.
Dachten wir.
Dachtest du.
Voll seoman.
Wir haben also jetzt sind sich sicher eigentlich so gut wie alles geklärt zu haben und es gibt ein echt spannendes Interviews mit dem nun scheidenden Brack
Präsidentin die Praktikums Rechtsanwaltskammer ja die Trägerin des Projektes tatsächlich mal ganz entspannendes.
Interview.
Sehr ausführlich denke mal hier nicht redigiert der also sagt,
wer ist eigentlich relativ zuversichtlich dass das jetzt so in Ordnung geht und,
dass das Projekt damit wenn man jetzt noch Mängel hat dann bessert man eben nachts ist es auf jeden Fall mal schön zu hören wie dieser Mann der viele Jahre,
terbrack Vorstand ich glaube 30 Jahre sagt er und nun dort geht als aus sagte.
Rdtw 30 Jahre lang da die Präsidentschaft gehabt und wenn er jetzt geht wird da wird er halt eben diesen Marlos tragen insofern ist ja der letzte der ist immer auf die leichte Schulter nimmt aber im gleichzeitig auch so ein bisschen
die Kirche im Dorf lassen möchte was ihn selber angeht da was die.
Massiver Packung des Projektes angeht das hat er ja nicht selber zu verantworten da hat er natürlich recht der gibt's ja auch.
Gesetzliche Vorgaben und eben ganz klein war das nie ihre Strenge Kompetenz Vorgabe Vergabe.
GFF klagt wegen der lachen musste ich wo er einen für Deutschland dann doch sehr schönen.
Auch die Mail,
welches vom Gesetz her als sicherer Übertragungsweg anerkannt ist benutzt keine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung in der Form in der sie nun von uns gefordert wird umgekehrt ist die Übertragung unter Einschaltung eines Hardware Security Models als sicherer Industriestandard anerkannt
das liebe Freunde ist genau der Grund warum man sowas lieber von Leuten machen lässt sich damit auskennen weil.
Bis um die De-Mail steht this way jetzt wirklich,
längerer Zeit und das da merkt man so richtig vom Gesetz her als sicher anerkannt das ist so ungefähr das hilft das was man haben,
wenn wenn etwas von Gesetze als sicher anerkannt ist ne danke dann weiß ich auch nicht mehr weiter ne.
Es gab dann noch so einen schönen gab dann noch so einen schönen Information liegt den dieses dieses Bea hatte und zwar konntest du dort sehen welche,
Anwaltskanzleien das Ding auch schon in Betrieb haben und hat Sally ist er per Gesetz so du bist ja verpflichtet als Anwalt dieses dieses Bea zu nutzen wenn es zur Verfügung steht seid in Kraft,
anquan mit Inkrafttreten des Gesetzes seit Bereitstellung des Dienstes musst du darüber erreichbar sein,
und es geht das hat ja die gleiche Falle vor der ich auch immer bei der De-Mail gewarnt habe warum ich auch bis heute kein De-Mail-Konto habe dass das Ding ja als zugestellt gilt ähnlich einem,
einer einem Einschreiben Einwurf Einschreiben und dass die Last bei dir liegt das dann auch zu lesen das heißt wenn du De-Mail-Konto hast musst du hoffen dass dir da keiner was hin schickt du hast mit ihr in einer Frist ist weil sonst stehst du nachher.
Mit der Hose runter da wir die Adolf Hitler Hooligans.
Und dass das geht eben bei dem Bea auch.
Und da kam jetzt Anwälte könnten passiert das tatsächlich Praxis ist also könnten quasi konnten quasi über dieses Information liegt nachschauen ob denn der Kollege dem sie jetzt Einschreiben zuschicken schon das Bier,
aktiviert hat unabhängig dessen konnten sie aber natürlich etwas dorthin schicken.
Und das wäre natürlich jetzt ein ein lustiger Trick als Anwalt zuschauen.
Noch nicht aktiviert aber wir stellt schon mal was.
Dessauer was zu ist ja dann eben Versäumnis des Kollegen ich weiß nicht ob das tatsächlich jemand gemacht hat aber natürlich darfst du so eine Information leakage auch nicht in so ein System haben also dürfen sie da ist Mama.
Am lebenden Objekt.
Sicher per Akklamation.
Warum ist schönes wenn Dinge von Gesetz her als sicher anerkannt sind hat uns auch Thomas noch mal kurz dran erinnert und fahr dich ja in der letzten Sendung schon darüber gesprochen.
Unser Thomas.
Unser Thomas glaube ich oder ein anderer Thomas der in Australien nein Thomas lonely,
auch ein seltenes Bild Thomas wobei Hemd hat das schon offen aber hat er schon oft aber aber zu.
Mercerisiert.
Wir wird langsam auch erwachsen wird.
Zusichern ne.
Nein der war letztens noch wieder auf einer Veranstaltung gestern da hat er auch wieder sauer ausleben krautundrueben bunten Hemd,
Thomas hat uns da ich hatte ja in der letzten Sendung meine meine Sorge geäußert.
Dass wir in mittlerer Zeit,
bei einer Debatte landen werden das eben Staatstrojaner Chartsoftware Spionage von staatlicher Seite gar nicht mehr unbedingt über Zero days eingespielt wird sondern dass die.
Ja das Gesetz erlassen werden die die Anbieter von Vater von Betriebssystemen von Applikationen verpflichten mitzuwirken.
Und Thomas kommentiert Heidi was ich befürchte du musst keine 12 Jahre mehr auf eingesetzt warten das diesen neuen Ansatz einer Bundestrojaner Infektion über Kooperation mit den Herstellern einführt
letzte Woche hat das kanadische Innenministerium das assistance entec destill vorgestellt das geht stark.
Diese Richtung dem vorangegangen oder dem mit dem einhergegangen ist auch.
Eine ein allgemeines Kommuniqué der,
five1 und ich glaube thomas hat hier zwei Länder verwechselt denn es handelt sich nicht um aus Kanada sondern um Australien die woher dieses assistance and accessible,
stammt oder ich habe halt jetzt eine ehrliche Bio einen ähnlichen Gesetzesvorschlag in Australien gefunden.
Viel wichtiger oder an Anfang möchte ich aber mit diesem Kommuniqué.
Der five 151 wissen wir der Zusammenschluss der Geheimdienste von USA Großbritannien Kanada Australien und Neuseeland.
Bitte was sagen die angelsächsische Welt.
Die angelsächsische Welt und zwar gibt es auch von der australischen Regierung veröffentlicht ein Statement.
Für die Prinzipien.
Beim Zugriff auf Beweismittel und Verschlüsselung das jetzt quasi einen eine Äußerung in der 51.
Gemeinsam der du sagen die Regierung der Vereinigten Staaten des vereinigten koenigreichs Kanadas Australien und Neuseeland,
bekennen sich zu persönlichen Rechten und Privatsphäre wenn ein Text schon so losgeht dann weißt du,
da kommt gleich ein großes aber und es dauert auch nicht lange da kommt nämlich dann ein großes however.
Muss auch Wurst.
So wir erkennen eure Rechte an wir sind klares Bekenntnis ja immer wenn sich jemand sie etwas bekennt weißt du dem Depp macht er jetzt kaputt.
Und sie haben dann also einen Text der sagt es gibt folgende drei Prinzipien erstens das Prinzip der gegenseitigen Verantwortung und einer gegenseitigen Verantwortlichkeit in sagen also wer,
Informationen bereitstellt und Kommunikationstechnologien bereitstellt.
Also die Netzbetreiber die Hersteller von den Geräten und auch die over-the-top Service-Provider unterliegen ein unterliegen dem Gesetz und dieses Gesetz Karten.
Beinhalten dass sie gezwungen sind den Strafverfolgungsbehörden Behörden zu helfen.
Mit anderen Worten Verschlüsselung ist kein rechtsfreier Raum.
Zweitens das zweite Prinzip.
The rule of law and due process a Paramount mit anderen Worten was weiß ich das Gesetz ist.
Muss einfach dem normalen Weg des Rechtswesens.
Gesetzes muss ein Weg des Gerätes Gesetz Wesens geben muss er so sagen alle Regierungen sollten sicherstellen dass wenn jemand um wenn hier jemand den Provider
um Hilfe bittet dass es dafür gesetzliche Regelungen gibt prinzipiell diesen Teil würde ich auch tatsächlich zustimmen
ja das muss er wenn die schon wenn schon irgendjemand einen Provider zur Mitwirkung zwingt dann bitte auf Basis eines Gesetzes,
nicht einer geheimen Paracord Anordnung nicht einer Erpressung oder einer freundschaftlichen Hilfe oder eines full-text AM dick sondern eingesetzt,
über das abgestimmt wurde ich sogar zustimmen.
Ich auch.
Aber jetzt sagen sie natürlich.
Also das muss diese Gesetze geben und es muss auch Kontrolle und so weiter gehen also ein klares Bekenntnis zum Rechtsstaat könnte man meinen denn den wir als nächstes platt machen denn sie sagen,
das dritte Prinzip was ich sehr schön finde ist das Prinzip der Wahlfreiheit das Prinzip der Wahlfreiheit ist sehr generös auf Englisch formuliert als freedom of choice for Love full access solutions,
und zwar ermutigen Sie die Betreiber und Hersteller freiwillig Möglichkeiten des law full access zu bauen.
Und die Regierung sollten keine spezifische Technologie,
bevorzugen stattdessen dürfen die Anbieter ihre eigenen Lösungen bauen die ihren spezifischen Systemarchitekturen angemessen sind,
und in der Lage sind die gesetzlichen Bestimmungen zu erreichen.
Jede Lösung kann ein konstruktiver Beitrag zu den aktuellen Herausforderungen sein sind also echt so großzügig dass sie sagen.
Unser Regal warte da einbaut Hauptsache kaputt.
Ihr euer Produkt kaputt macht hauptsache ihr macht das und dann denkst du ja ist doch super voll geil ein tolles Bekenntnis der Fall weissagen.
Dann kommt ihr letzter Satz.
To governments continue to encounter impediments to love all access to information.
Mit anderen Worten sollten wir weiterhin Einschränkungen und Behinderungen erfahren.
Dann könnte es sein dass wir technologische Wege Legislative erwäge Wege oder auch den Weg des Zwanges nutzen.
Um die Zugänge zu bekommen die uns gesetzlich zustehen.
Das ist sehr sehr unverhohlene Drohung.
Und das dass es ein klarer Bezug auf.
Das was wir hier im Thema Staatstrojaner hatten ja also ihr habt eine Verantwortung dafür dass wir darauf Zugriff kriegen nicht wir.
Wirtschaften Gesetze dafür die wandern ja durch den Bundestag haben wir ja gesehen und wie geht's euch sogar noch die Frau ist völlig egal wir eure Nutzer in den Rücken stärkt hauptsache wir kriegen was wir heute solltet ihr das nicht tun.
Haben wir auch andere Mittel.
Wie heißt es so schön im Erlkönig ich liebe dich mich reizt deine schöne Gestalt und bist du nicht willig so brauche ich.
Das ist so da merkst du auch eine Kehrtwende und zwar na ja ziemlich genau die die ich ja auch nicht in der letzten Sendung berichtet habe eben in vielen Gesprächen schon gewittert habe,
und dass sie in dieser Form kommt.
Also sprach Linus Neumann weißt schon in dem Bereich den du immer so lustig Kurzmeldung nennst.
Kommt drauf an wie ausführlich du jetzt über die Kreditkarte Transaktionsdaten sprechen möchtest.
Ja also da gibt's glaube ich,
gar nicht so viel zu berichten es gab eine Meldung die Kammer Bloomberg raus da sind wohl verschiedene anonyme Quellen die übereinstimmen berichteten aufgetreten und die auch,
teilweise daran mitgearbeitet haben bei Google an einem Programm wo Google wohl,
Noten berichten mehrere Jahre lang mit Mastercard verhandelt hat und dann auf ein agreement gekommen ist wie man denn,
Klicks auf online Werbeanzeigen zurückführen kann auch später.
Getätigte Käufe mit Mastercard Kreditkarten Hintergrund ist halt wie man quasi,
Online-Werbung zusammenbringen kann mit einem späteren Kauf oder sprich hat das Einblenden irgendeiner Anzeige dazu geführt dass eine Person unabhängig von einem online
Shopping Vorgang der da mehr oder weniger direkt einfach getrackt werden kann ob das dann später erfolgt,
das technisch genau aussah gibt dieser Artikel jetzt glaube ich nicht her,
so oder so hatte das tracking was dort stattgefunden hat ohne Kenntnis der Karteninhaber
stattgefunden und beide Unternehmen haben wohl auch davon abgesehen ihre Kunden darüber zu informieren und ja das wird halt einfach,
vor dem Hintergrund gesehen dass Google versucht hier sein Werbegeschenk Werbegeschenk sehr schön sind Werte Geschäfter zu stark.
Google ist ein Werbegeschenk was ist eigentlich keine schlechte Idee das Werbegeschenk.
Ja also angeblich greift das tracking nur bei Benutzer in die halt bei Google auch wirklich angemeldet sind,
Klarna aber dann kann man halt davon ausgehen dass in dem Fall den Werbetreibenden umfangreiche Profilinformationen zugegangen sind wenn ich direkt welche Person hier aktiv wurde soll fragen,
was eben sonst noch bei Google alles so gespeichert ist,
und mein habe das wohl auch abschalten können der optout hat sich nicht unbedingt aufgedrungen also wenn man dabei Web und activity bei
Google die entsprechenden Haken gesetzt hat dann
sei mal da auch nicht ausgeliefert wird aber es zeigt halt einfach mal wieder dass dieses Unternehmen keine Möglichkeiten auslässt um daten zusammenzuführen.
Ich finde mich ausspannen dass diese Daten diese Datenweitergabe verwirken von den Kreditkarten da gibt's tatsächlich ein ausführen
opt-out-möglichkeit na da kannst du deine Kreditkarte Katze quasi sagen hier ach übrigens ich will gar nicht dass ihr meine Zahlungsdaten an andere verkaufen könnt liebe Mastercard lieber Visa
ich habe das mal versucht aber da kommen immer irgend welche ROF.
Das auch ganz komisch dass die Systeme dann immer so schlecht funktionieren.
Funktioniert Carly.
Ja wie alt ist kaputt ist auf dem Formular genau in den drei Tagen wo die Menschheit nicht da mal eben für interessiert ja tut es leid das war ein Bug das geht jetzt wieder,
achso nee sie müssen noch die müssen ihre Nummer ihre Geheimnummer Nummer 5 eingeben die war auf der divine auf dem Briefumschlag drauf also in vor sieben Jahren die Karte geschickt haben kann sie nicht mehr,
schick mir eine neue zu.
Schicken Sie uns dafür folgendes ausgeformt ausgefülltes Formular per Post.
Passierschein A38.
Haben sie auch haben sie einen 27b.
Wie geht das rund Sohn komm jetzt zu einem.
Völlig anderen Thema.
Zu einem völlig anderen Thema wir haben ja hier vor einigen Wochen auch über die Hausdurchsuchung bei denen,
Mitgliederorganisationen des Chaos Computer Clubs gesprochen insbesonder einmal das Chaos Treff Dortmund und der.
Der ist oben bleibt in Augsburg und da kannst jetzt eine schöne kleine Anfrage im in Nordrhein-Westfalen sind für Dortmund wohl dann,
also die Linke im Landtag gefragt hat hier so eine,
wie sieht's denn hier aus was war denn da ihr vife für Durchsuchung wieder stattgefunden haben warum wurden der andere Räume durchsucht er sagen das ist die Antwort die Räumlichkeiten des betreffenden Gebäudes waren einzelne Nutzer nicht zuzuordnen,
für
zuzuordnen vor Ort anwesende Personen operierten nicht da auch sonst keine Hinweise auf den gesuchten Raum erlangt werden konnten wurden alle in Frage kommenden Räume betreten aber nicht durchsucht,
eine Durchsuchung eines anderen Raum ist als das durch die Beschlüsse abgedeckten Geschäftsraum des wissenschaftsladen erfolgten nicht und da fragst du dich ernsthaft,
das ist ja irgendwie tatsächlich sehr nachvollziehbar gelogen ich war ja schon im Chaostreff Dortmund und die haben in diesem Haus natürlich also das ist aus ja da gibt's Türen,
gibt's im Flur gibt's Etagen jetzt klingelt der steht dran wer da wohnt,
holzbriefkästen da steht dran das Briefkasten Dortmund Briefkasten der ganz so also zu sagen sie die Räumlichkeiten des Gebäudes waren einzelne Nutzer nicht zuzuordnen ist schon echt.
Also so blöd sind 47 Polizisten in Nordrhein-Westfalen nicht
vor Ort anwesende Personen operierten nicht der Lächerlichkeit ganz im Gegenteil die Mitglieder des Chaos Treff Dortmund haben ja Türen aufgemacht die haben ja sogar obwohl sie,
das nicht hätten tun müssen und das auch einen Bruch ihre eigenen Rechte war sie hier wie auf Sofa gesetzte Telefon vor die Tür vor ihr vor sich hingelegt weil ja die Polizei sicherstellt wollte das jetzt nicht telefonieren z.b. ein Anwalt anrufen oder so.
Dann sagen Sie es wurde nicht durchsucht der fragst du dich wieso wurden die denn da mehrere Stunden auf dem Sofa sitzen mit Handy auf dem Tisch wo ich es sehen kann in Ihrem Gebäude festgehalten werden die durch den durch die durch die Träume gegangen sind,
was ist das denn dann wenn es keine Durchsuchung ist,
und das ist eben in anderen Räumen als den des wissenschaftsladen nicht erfolgt sei der Fachmann sichern und wirklich was da los ist des Weiteren wurden gemäß wird in der Kleinen Anfrage gefragt wo wohnen denn überall.
Was wurde denn alles beschlagnahmt mit'm I III Nogi Dinge beschlagnahmen und sagen wir haben wir waren nur in dem einen Raum rein beschlagnahmen aber zu rächen auf verschiedenen Etagen wo auf jeder Etage auch dran steht wer da wohnt,
hätte jetzt nachfragen können aber ich glaube der Chaostreff ist in Wien der zweite Tag also bei denen wurde nichts.
Wurde nichts beschlagnahmt dann sind die Räume des durchsuche Kulturzentrums nun Gegenstand von Überwachungsmaßnahmen zu etwaigen verdeckten Maßnahmen nimmt die Landesregierung öffentlich keine Stellung ja klar dass es,
dann hat das,
und dann wird in Gefahr zu wer war dabei insgesamt vier und 47 Mitarbeiterin Mitarbeiter des Landeskriminalamtes Nordrhein-Westfalen die sich offenbar nicht in der Lage sein einfache,
Schilder an Türen zu erkennen also wirklich eine das wirkliche.
Es war ja auch lesen.
Ja da sind,
vielleicht war nicht so aufgeregt aber das ist wirklich der Sohn sitzt zu sagen sie sehr in diesem in diesem Gebäude der das nicht einzelnen Nutzern zuordenbar gewesen sie hätten andere Räume nicht durchsucht das ist natürlich schon echt,
starke Stück und das ist immer genau das was ich auch in der Folge als wir von den sieben Freunden zu Gast hatten,
angesprochen habe das nämlich tatsächlich diese am Ende sagen wer ihr seid ihr jetzt schon.
Wir haben deine Frage kommen habe gesagt guter Polizei Hausdurchsuchung machen wir gerade Wohnung und dann die gesagt ja kommen sie doch rein dann wir Gefahr können uns mal kurz und gucken haben ja gesagt das ist keine Hausdurchsuchung wären wir fertig gebracht haben sehr hereingebeten.
Ach die machen nach Hausdurchsuchung können Sie bei uns dann vielleicht auch weil das bei uns ja schon lange nicht mehr durchsucht worden.
Besuchen auch gerade was.
Wir haben heuer also wir finden auch verschiedene Sachen gar nicht mehr.
Können Sie die Handys bitte mal auf den Tisch legen wo ich sie sehe ja klar na das immer unglaublich.
Das schon krass aber man fragt sich natürlich dann so okay sind die so doof oder ist das Absicht.
Also man kann das nicht abschließend beurteilen aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass ist so doof sind ich weiß nicht wenn man sie jetzt selber fragen würde sagen Sie mal sind sie eigentlich so doof dann.
Sammelband Laufbahn und so wir können auch lesen und schreiben.
Er muss wissen so bye bye bye bye well Polizeibeamten ist das noch nicht lange so dass man dann Fachabitur verlangt als mindestausbildung.
Was heißt das nicht danke.
Darf jetzt vielleicht 10-15 Jahre oder sowas wurde dann irgendwann sein.
Echte Polizei braucht man einfach ab.
Wenn es also oder du also täusch ich mich war ich war schockiert als ich das gelesen habe dass man eben mit dem mit einem wenn man das jetzt die Schule hinter sich hatte.
Dahin konnte ja aber die haben auch eine polizeihochschule und deswegen im Fachhochschule für Polizei und deswegen glaube ich eben Fachabitur.
Okay na gut also man
deswegen meine ich halt gerade also wenn man sich halt fragt ob die wirklich so doof sind dann kann man irgendwie schon sim.com so ist eigentlich eher unwahrscheinlich dass ich so doof sind und wenn sie halt nicht so doof sind trotzdem aber falsch machen was ist dann die Motivation,
oder was die Ursache sozusagen davon und es drängt sich ein wenig der Eindruck auf das hier dann doch wissen die ich,
über die gesetzten Grenzen hinweg gegangen wird mit der Intention,
nicht nur weiteres Material zu finden,
sei eben hier schlicht und ergreifen die Gelegenheit zu nutzen der gesamten Zähne so ein bisschen Schokotorte.
Kurz kurz direktkurier urkultur Voraussetzung für den mittleren Polizeivollzugsdienst
zwischen 16 und 27 Jahre alt ausnahmen sind möglich wenn du eine Berufsausbildung abgeschlossen hast und mehr als 3 Jahre Berufserfahrung mitbringst darfst du höchstens 35 Jahre alt sein.
Bald deinen Realschulabschluss machen oder die mittlere Reife bereits in der Tasche hast also nein muss kein Wort kein Abitur.
Fachabitur brauchst du für den.
Höhere Laufbahn.
Gehobenen Dienst bei Abitur oder Fachabitur machen oder dein Arsch ist bereits in der Tasche haben und höchstens 33 Jahre alt dann kannst du in den gehobenen Polizeivollzugsdienst.
Aber könnte schon davon ausgehen dass irgendeiner den diesem Bereich fällt an dieser Aktion auch beteiligt war also irgendeiner hat.
Aber Tim weißt du was für den mittlerer Polizeivollzugsdienst sehr brauchst du Deutsch mindestens die Note 4 Alter.
Ich will gerade was die an Mindestanforderung erlischt für so einen Podcast sind.
Mindestens Note 4.
Ist einfach mal mach mal ein Abschluss mit einer 5 in Deutsch durch bekanntzumachen nachher das wird eng.
Okay kommen wir weiter es gibt da Tür.
Aber leute Leute die können ganz beruhigt sein als der Dino hat der hat ja studiert und ich habe Abi.
Ich habe auch Abi Alter.
Ich weiß nicht mehr was ich dort Schatz habe was war gerade hier.
Ich habe mal nach Mutter bestimmt ja immer mein Abiturzeugnis haben ja jetzt mein Abiturzeugnis.
Oh krass okay hast du das.
Ja also weiß ich besonders gut aber.
Stetten.
Oder muss.
Wie das ist.
Das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Ist es nicht es ist nicht in 1 bis 6 Noten sondern es ist in 1 bis 15 Punkten und steht dann im Zeugnis auch noch in der Vervielfachung für die Gesamtnote.
Wurde das Abiturzeugnis ich eh getanzt.
Also ich hatte 10 10 von 15 Punkten in Deutsch reicht das.
Guck mal hier ich gucke mal eben vielleicht finde ich hier in alten Bewerbung noch mein Abiturzeugnis.
Nee ich habe offenbar.
Amazon,
Durchschnittsnote 2,5 David darf man Polizist werden und Podcaster.
Ohohohohoh Olten.
Brüssel.
Will ich in meine Noten sage.
Liebe ich liebe den Durchschnitt.
Clip den Durchschnitt.
Na du hast doch bestimmt wieder Streber das lass mal weg jetzt.
Ich guck mal ganz kurz euch das finde nee ich finde echt nicht.
Na hast du doch großes Wohnzimmer noch nicht unter andere Staatsbürgerschaft.
Kenn ich kenn ich kenne die Noten tatsächlich sage ich dir nachher.
Okay dann weiß ich später,
jut.
Ja zwiebelfreunde Durchsuchung habe ich ja erwähnt da gibt's jetzt ein Urteil des Landgerichts München I.
Außer überraschend.
Die angegriffene Durchsuchung und Beschlagnahme Beschlüsse und Beschlagnahme Bestätigungs Beschlüsse des Amtsgerichts München waren rechtswidrig sind deshalb aufzuheben soweit sie noch Bestand haben,
übrigens war ihre Rechtswidrigkeit festzustellen den Anträgen auf Herausgabe der beschlagnahmten Gegenstände war insofern
ebenfalls Stadt zu gehen mit anderen Worten die haben ihren Zeug wieder und die gesamten durch die gesamte Durchsuchungen war rechtswidrig wie wär's auch schon gesagt haben,
und die Mail Edikt ja also schön dass das jetzt Ihren
in-münchen zumindest ihren Kram zurückkriegen das betrifft natürlich im Zweifelsfall noch nicht die Durchsuchung in anderen an anderen Orten.
Mais in Augsburg.
Naja Augsburg gehört jetzt zu Bayern deswegen Landgericht München aber es gab ja noch Jena und Berlin,
darüber ist das dass der Friedbert ich jetzt noch nicht zu ist aber natürlich hoffentlich davon auszugehen dass es eben mit beginnt genauso entschieden werden wird weil die ja mit der gleichen Begründung,
wann gibt's jetzt wurden und das dann gleich Mädchen sagt es gibt keine Anhaltspunkte dass die betroffene deren Verein zwiebelfreunde Frau oder die Gruppierung wiseup Network Network auch nur zum
Umfeld der unbekannten Täter gehören Täter wir erinnern uns die Verfasserinnen oder Verfasser des Reiseführers,
Augsburg für krawalltouristen.
Es ist zudem auch nicht unmittelbar ersichtlich dass sich dass sich bei Ihnen Informationen zum Täter Umfeld oder zu den Tätern finden lassen einziger Verbindung
Punkt ist der Umstand dass die unbekannten Täter bei riseup.net ist ein E-Mail Konto eingerichtet hatten riseup.net bietet allerdings bestimmungsgemäß anonymisierte Internet Dienste an die Einrichtung dieser Kontos kann auf Empfehlung anonym erfolgen der
E-Mail Verkehr über das eingerichtet Konto erfolgte,
verschlüsselt der ist wegen besteht nur sehr geringe Wahrscheinlichkeit überweisungs und dessen Datenstand Informationen zu den Tätern.
Daten zu erhalten ergänzen kommt hier noch hinzu dass die betroffene mit ihrem Verein zwiebelfreunde e.v. nach bisher Informationsstand nicht mit rise up Networks gleichgesetzt werden können,
die Verbindung besteht soweit ersichtlich nur in der Unterstützung des Networks durch das Sammeln von Spenden ja.
Hätte man auch schneller feststellen können.
Hätte das Amtsgericht München auch feststellen können und hat jetzt eben von seiner von seinem Landgericht entsprechend ein offen Sack.
Schön hier doch mal eine gute Nachricht und werd noch eine gute Nachricht,
es gibt die Science Europe coalition es,
also Buchstaben die jetzt gesagt hat ha wir werden ab ich glaube 20 20.
Nur noch Projekte fördern die ihre ver.di ihre Veröffentlichungen dann am Ende in open-access machen deswegen ist auch das,
oan coalition.
Gutgeschrieben für Open Access ja und sagen Sie in diesem Rahmen besagen wir wollen offene Archive offene Repositories publishing und so weiter nach dem 1. Januar.
Dürr werden wir nur noch müssen alle von uns gefahndet and Studien,
in mit unseren Regeln übereinstimmen Eck Open Access journals veröffentlicht werden.
Und wer macht da mit sehr schön,
Österreich Frankreich Irland Italien Luxemburg die Niederlande Norwegen Polen Slowenien Schweden sogar das Vereinigte Königreich und die Europäische Kommission,
inklusive des European Research Council Wer war wieder nicht dabei Schland.
Ja aber vielleicht,
wird sich das alte Europa hier diesen Plan beugen das ist ja schön warum das alles so ein großes Problem ist haben wir ja behandeln lassen bei machen kann ja auch einfach mal outsourcen,
an unsere Freunde von methodisch inkorrekt die das in der PRI Show von LMP 200.
So schön vorgetragen haben in,
wie an der Universität üblich einer man Niveau der Vortragende quasi zum zu Beamer Leinwand spricht und nicht etwa zum Publikum wo wir extra da ein,
was ist ein universitäres Umfeld das ziemt sich dann nicht zum Publikum zu sprechen das versteht sie nicht der Führer aber da wurde das Thema ja ausführlich behandelt und ich finde dass das ist eine gute Nachricht.
Man kann aber jetzt auch nicht sagen was in Deutschland hier keine Aktivität ist in meinem Handy das hier von der EU-Kommission aus das ist schon mal sehr gut und insofern
sollten sich auch alles mal ausreichend vertreten fühlen dabei ich denke ohnehin dass wir hier den TippingPoint schon erreicht haben es gibt ja in Deutschland das Projektil,
was kann ich habe darüber schon mal gesprochen haben das sicherlich am Rande ja auch schon mal einen geflochten wo ja gerade versucht wird mit den großen Journalen,
einen neuen Deal auszuhandeln.
Näher mit Elsevier ca sozusagen also die haben ja alle Zugänge gekündigt,
oh du bist ja auch knallhart geblieben gegenüber Elsevier so dass du sagen der der Zugang wenn ich mich jetzt nicht recht täusche,
ist es derzeit so dass die Universitäten gerade keinen Zugang haben weil,
so eine Übergangszeit von drei Monaten die Elsevier wohl freundlicherweise selber noch eingerichtet hat nach dem Auslaufen der alten Verträge mit auch abgelaufen.
Was heißt die Universitäten können derzeit eigentlich auf die ganzen papers nur noch über Sekundärquellen zugreifen ja im übrigen
hi hab z.b. Russia durchaus ergiebig ist so wasowo wie alles zu finden ist auch wenn es ein bisschen Wii mit Park Bevensen
Hasen schießen Asterode ist gerade sozusagen die Domain of the day gerade läuft aber
das hat mich alles nicht einzufangen und der Trend ist schon ganz klar wenn man hat es jetzt einfach in der Wissenschaft komplett schon eingesehen zumindest die progressiven Kräfte die hier offensichtlich auch auf dem,
die Überhand gewonnen haben gegenüber den Traditionalisten denen das egal war weil die schon alle überall in den Journalen vertreten waren.
Der Trend ist meiner Meinung nach irreversibel aber noch nicht ab.
Der anders wär sie auch nicht zu erklären dass die Politik sich plötzlich auch in diese Richtung ausrichtet ne.
Ja
Das hast doch schon richtig guten Tag.
Ja das war ich auch gerade sagen ne ansonsten ist Umsetzungszeit,
von EU Richtlinien unter anderem der EU-Richtlinie zum sogenannten passenger Name record PNR auch Fluggastdaten genannt.
Lastarten Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Genau erinnern uns das war eine nicht ausreichen stopbar Initiative auf EU-Ebene wo gefordert und jetzt ist auch beschlossen wurde
das doch bitte alle Flugreise Betreiber Reisebüros,
und sonstige Reiseanbieter umfangreiche Daten über Flugreisende bereithalten müssen bzw nur bereithalten müssen sollen an die Behörden abliefern müssen.
Zentral gesammelt schöne Datenbank.
Dazu gibt es eine EU Richtlinie diese ist jetzt gültig im Mai bis Mai sollte quasi die Umsetzung in allen Ländern erfolgt sein,
dem ist insofern wohl auch Folge geleistet worden als dass alle EU-Länder eine entsprechendes fluggastdatengesetz,
erlassen haben teilweise fehlt aber wohl noch die offizielle Rückmeldung gegenüber der EU
dass das jetzt so sagen vollumfänglich auch alles in Betrieb genommen worden ist weil das Gesetz ist ja nur ein Teil davon andererseits müssen die Länder halt auch noch eine entsprechende Daten sammelt Zentralstelle einrichten
Deutschland scheint ja auf jeden Fall bisschen weiter zu sein als andere.
Da sind wir wieder vorne.
Das war vorne weil dazu brauchen wegen Terror.
Datenexport Weltmeister.
Genaue was muss er jetzt irgendwie passieren.
Die Betroffenen,
Gruppen müssen diese PNR Daten bis spätestens 24 Stunden vor der planmäßigen Abflugzeit übermitteln an diese Zentralstelle,
und dann aber auch noch ein zweites Mal bist du schon heiß wenn sich die Türen des starten Flugzeuges endgültig,
geschlossen haben dies würde dann z.b. ermöglichen mehr oder weniger in Echtzeit festzustellen werde nicht an Bord gegangen ist mich also gibt ja auch viele Leute die verpassen malen Flug.
Könnten ja aber gerne mal durchgeben diese Leute,
die ihr Gepäck aufgeben und dann nicht in der blöde Flugzeug gehen und dann kommt jedesmal leider ist der Arsch hier nicht gekommen wir müssen jetzt den Koffer rausholen weil die sicherheitsvorschrift ne,
jedes Mal Verzögerung.
Segnungen und Probleme von Vielflieger.
Manchmal auch sofort mal da könnte man sofort mal die Daten durchgeben.
BNR sonst auch hier Kreditkarte card verification code dass man direkt auf deren Namen sich noch mal ne ja solche ne das geht so nicht Kinder.
Müssen noch zu Menschenhasser wird kann das sein dass den schlecht geworden ist das überfallen worden sind dass die krank geworden sind.
Überfallen am Flughafen ne in der Sicherheitszone womit denn mit einer.
Na die sind ja nicht zwangsläufig nicht du kannst ja dass dein Gepäck erst abgeben muss es auch teilweise dass es nicht in der sicher.
Mann gibt seinen Gepäck ihr nicht ab,
das wird doch eh nur verklüngelt also wer das ist sowieso das erste der da geht schon los im Zählernummer 1 Mann gibt kein Gepäck auf tut man nicht weil du dann weil die Depfa klüngeln und dann hängst du nachher da und kriegst deinen Koffer nicht.
Was heißt verstümmeln verlieren.
Ja sicher DDR wann hast du hier also.
Also ich habe die meisten Koffer bisher wieder.
Ja irgendwann in welchem Zustand denn nein das macht man nicht man fliegt mit den Standard Koffern die da oben reinpassen und das muss dann auch reichen,
wer geht mehr Gepäck hat muss eben in der höhere Buchungsklasse gehen wo man zwei oder drei Gepäckstücke mitnehmen kann aber auch irgendwie hast du dir mal die.
Red du redest dich jetzt wieder um Kopf und Kragen Dinos warum machst du das.
Ich gehe doch nicht meinen Koffer den Adolf Hitler Hooligans die da unten die im mit den Koffern rum.
Du hast halt keine Kinder und deswegen hast du keine Gepäck drop.
Noch nicht in Koffer Themen.
Milch.
Vielleicht habe ich alles falsch gemacht lassen wir das.
Was für Daten hätten Sie denn gerne also übermittelt wird unter anderem Informationen zum Reiseverlauf zum Mitreisenden Zwischenstopps dabei gebuchten Hotels oder Mietwagen.
Ja also wer immer diese ganzen Kombi Buchungen Macht über die Fluglinie ca und Bruse doch noch ein Hotel und Puzzle noch ein Mietwagen dass es dann halt quasi auch noch alles mit drauf,
sämtliche bei der Buchung anfallende kontaktangaben,
unter anderem die E-Mail-Adresse Rechnungsanschrift Angaben zum Reisebüro so meinen 1 eingesetzt hat auch,
Sachbearbeiter und Sachbearbeiterin in Sprachen mit fliegenden Minderjähriger.
Welche Fahne ist.
Also essensvorlieben.
Oder ob du einen Doktortitel hast oder nicht also eine Geschichten die Liste ist jetzt glaube ich nicht vollständig so oder so wird das Ganze dann noch fünf Jahre lang vorgehalten.
Ja viel Spaß beim Fliegen wünschen wir euch ist jetzt total sicher.
Ja das hat es jetzt das Herz gebracht,
vollständige Überwachung des des Flugverkehrs Dad hat der braucht man noch was habe ich dich damit wir sicher sind.
Ja ich weiß jetzt gar nicht ob ich meine Befürchtungen jetzt noch äußern soll weil ich habe einfach Angst wenn ich dir jetzt sage dann treten noch zwei Monate früher in Kraft als es ohnehin schon tun würden.
Es ist ja toll also es gibt halt einfach bald es muss einfach alles verdattert werden und es wird nicht weniger.
Was mit dem Server ein.
Der timer ja also das halber war viel los aber unsere Sendung ist lang genug und irgendwie ich muss immer irgendwie überlegen ob man da nicht auch irgendwie war hier in der Ecke macht oder so aber heute gibt's weniger teilbar,
nein also heute gibt es nicht zu viel wie Insider losfahren wir sparen uns diese Nordkorea Hacker Problematik wir sparen uns so schöne Sachen die pexploit so interessant das auch sein mag wir stellen einfach nur fest,
in Deutschland kam er irgendwie mit dem Cyber nicht so viel über die da sind wir,
auch Daten Exportweltmeister und jetzt haben.
Ursula von der Leyen und Horst Seehofer gemeinsam die Agentur für cybersicherheit ins Leben gerufen.
Die das offizielle Ziel hat ambitionierte Forschungs und Innovationsvorhaben anzustoßen zu fördern und zu finanzieren.
Und so irgendwie diesen Prozess dann von der Idee bis zum Produkt zu koordinieren mit 100 Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern.
Also die an den ID Sicherheitslösungen von morgen zu forschen,
asi.at Sicherheitslösungen von morgen müssen ja heute schon erforscht werden damit sie morgen dann vom Gesetz her als sicher anerkannt werden können.
Das ist ja klar und das soll aber dann natürlich die Forschung selber soll vom vom Meer von der Privatwirtschaft dann betrieben werden die Projekte sollen eher gefördert werden und,
nennt er jetzt als Beispiel Systeme auf Basis quantenmechanische Zustände quantencomputing also ein forschungsforum der aber natürlich.
Grundsätzlich keine schlechte Idee ist aber wenn eine grundsätzlich nicht schlechte Idee von Ursula von der Leyen und Horst Seehofer kommt da kann halt nicht sein.
Bitte mir nicht so sicher ob das für die ihre Idee ist.
Beste aber wenn sie das nicht verhindert haben wenn sie sich einer guten Idee nicht in den Weg gestellt haben dann kann es keine gute Idee sein.
Dürfen nicht vergessen gleichzeitig diskutieren wir auf vielen Ebenen wieder.
Die Ideen für eine rechtliche Grundlage für Hack und Back,
ja der BND will diese rechtliche Grundlage bekommen Seehofer will den Bären diese Möglichkeit schaffen sie auf der sagt ich bin entschieden dafür dass wir uns,
immer nach dem Prinzip der Verhältnismäßigkeit den politischen
und rechtlichen Rahmen schaffen für ein abgestuftes Vorgehen wo am Ende in einer besonderen Situation auf einer klaren Grundlage für den zivilen Bereich auch dieser Gegenangriff sozusagen ermöglicht werden soll,
sozusagen,
Pack und Pack ja das ist in diesem Rahmen der gleiche Seehofer will er jetzt hier eine Agentur für cybersicherheit haben wir haben als CCC und dazu auf positioniert und haben ein ganz einfach verlangt wir wollen.
Eine rein Defensive cyber-sicherheitsstrategie und 2 teilbar defensiv heißt Sachen werden in sicher gebaut.
Und Verteidigung ist eben nicht Angriff es ist diese diese gesamte Idee eines Hack und Back ist eben Quatsch es gibt nicht die Situation in der.
Irgendwie ein ein tatsächlicher Heckmeck einer eine solche mal eine Katastrophe in ihrem Ausmaß mindern würde,
das gibt es einfach nicht er ist wäre jetzt das einzige Beispiel was dem am nächsten kommt,
ist diese diese wannacry Situation wo das wo die mayware versucht hat zu zu gucken ob sie eine ob sie,
in einer Sandbox ist weil sie diesen DNS requests gemacht hat und wenn der beantwortet wurde hat sie ja quasi nicht weiter gemacht dass er und dann hat er derjenige der es analysiert hat,
diese Domain registriert und dadurch wannacry an der Ausbreitung gehindert ja das habe ich auch keinen Heckmeck.
So die die Situation von der immer alle fabulieren ist da gibt es einen Cyber an da gibt's einen DDoS-Angriff und wir müssen den Server hacken von dem der ausgeht so ein Quatsch wenn du einen wenn du
Ziel eines DDoS-Angriff bis dann musst du deine Firewall um konfigurieren und oder dich zu einem höchst Hochverfügbarkeit Dienstleister temporär bewegen aber nicht den Server von dem der distributed
da Denial-of-Service Angriff ausgeht das ist alles Stuss,
insofern würde man sich hier keinen Zacken aus der Krone brechen einfach mal zu sagen wir bekennen uns Villingen fest,
dass wir nicht mit Seilbahn,
dass wir unsere Schwerpunkte bei der Verteidigung legen dass wir rein defensiv vorgehen dass wir rein Defensive Forschungsbudget es haben dass wir ein Interesse haben sowohl unsere eigenen Infrastrukturen als auch,
uns anvertraute Zivilgesellschaft in diesem Lande zu schützen und dafür das Geld zu verwenden es wäre also.
Wir liefern keine Sniper Waffen in Krisengebiete.
Also.
Wir werde diese diese diese gesamte Idee des Hack und Bugs ist totaler Quatsch aber klar der BND soll bisher hat bisher diese exekutivbefugnisse nicht er hat nur eben diese Spionage Befugnisse und das soll unsere Bundesregierung,
Ändern gleichzeitig bautizo eine Agentur auf für cybersicherheit ja Ministerium für Wahrheit kommt als nächstes das ist also ich meine erstmal.
Würde ich noch Rissquetschwunde für dich noch.
Das bluetooth soll natürlich was denkst du denn aber.
Den Fake News.
Ministerium für Wahrheit.
Ist mir gerade wieder angeguckt in London.
Naja aber also wir beobachten das jetzt mal aber ohne in den Händen von Verteidigungsministerium und,
Innenministerium und unter Einfluss von Seehofer und von allein kann man selbst bei einer guten Idee nur das Schlimmste befürchten.
Will ich das Ding nicht von vornherein verdammen aber ich denke an dieser Stelle auch nochmals CCC zu sagen hier
wäre klug das nicht zu tun sondern hier auf eine sinnvolle Strategie hinzuarbeiten,
auf jeden Fall notwendig um hier die Zeichen der Zeit richtig zu doll.
Oder z.b. diese Quantencomputer Geschichte durchaus auch hin deutet also ich mein das ist nur eine reale Bedrohung unseres.
Auch unseres Sicherheitssystems unser unser aller Sicherheitssystems reitergrund einfach Ball nicht ganz klar ist wann und wenn in welcher Form,
ist aber durchaus vorstellbar ist das eben die Quantencomputer in dem Moment wo sie möglich werden im mal eben die komplette Grundlage unserer derzeitigen Kryptographie brechen und das ist etwas worauf man sich vorbereiten muss ist schon okay.
Ja das dass ich bin ja mal gespannt ob sie das Fördern werden.
Nerf.
Das müssen wir dann eben tatsächlich werden wir erleben das sind wir.
Mensana.
Am Ende der Sendung.
War lang genug nächste Mal lass es immer so silbern lange sein und jeder die länger die Pause desto Sendung.
Ja na ja.
Weißt du noch jemanden danken spezifisch was macht das projekt 1001.
1001 ist sehr gut gelaufen mich mich ausgiebig bei all denen bedanken die halt dieses explizite regelmäßige unterstützen eingeleitet haben so klein die Spinnen auch sind,
alles hilft und macht die Metaebene deutlich besser planbar ist das noch vor wenigen Monaten der Fall war,
sofern freue ich mich über alle die da schon zugeschlagen haben und natürlich über alle die das noch erwägen.
Außerdem sollten wir uns über Schlaf unterhalten Tim auf der neuen Matratze von hast du nicht gesehen nur mal hier so eine kleine Drogen in den Ronny Pfeiffer ist weißt du wir ermutigen alle zu Spenden für die Metaebene.
Darf ich ja ganz andere sagen gehen.
Mit kommt einfach nicht bis ganz einfach also entweder entweder alles werbefrei oder halt gar nicht,
Bittersalz Drogen nicht ausreicht.
Willst feiner Knabe du mit mir gehen,
meine Töchter sollen dich warten schön meine Töchter führen den nächtlichen reihn und wiegen und tanzen und singen dich ein.
Das ist auch der Erlkönig ja.
Muss ich mal auswendig lernen das war auch bei uns bei dir du hast du ja einen Abitur erinnert da haben Freunde von mir den auch vertont das war sehr schön,
zu mieten zum heavy metal Ballade auf dem Erlkönig gemacht weil man zu der Erkenntnis sagen dann top Namen und wenn dann dieses
ist aber so aufgebaut nennt man,
mein Vater mein Vater dann das Kind noch siehst du nicht dort Erlkönigs Töchter am düstern Ort und dann hatte mein Sohn mein Sohn ich sehe es genau es scheinen die alten Weiden so grau,
ja und dann am Ende kam dann natürlich das Kind war tot,
verarschen.
Ist es halt ein schönes Gedicht wenn man kannst ja auch auf auf alle Fälle umtexten gibt's bestimmt doch eine Podcasting Version von dich oder nicht.
Packers bisschen Kurzfilm partenkasten.
Ja wer sendet so spät noch bei Nacht und Wind.
Das hätten wir auch als Regenwald methodisch inkorrekt als Intro vorführen können.
Sophie.
So viele Möglichkeiten aber weißt du welche Möglichkeit ich genutzt habe das kann ich ja jetzt schon mal ankündigen ich werde am Montag Podcast Geschichte schreiben Geschichte Geschicht.
Geschichte.
Mit dem Kohlenpott denn Christian und ich machen am Montag Vodkas Gruben Ruben Crawford Grubenfahrt auf Prosper.
Welcher welcher Rechten also welchen welchen Slot in der Ewigen Erzählung unsere der Menschheitsgeschichte gedenkst du dazu füllen.
Erster und letzter Podcast von untertage.
Von und mit dir was ist gerade noch nie ein Podcast der untertage aufgenommen wurde.
Nee du brauchst nämlich ein explosionsgeschütztes Aufnahmegerät.
Explosionsgeschütztes Aufnahme.
Explosionsgeschütztes Aufnahmegerät.
Du bist sagen meine sind unter Umständen nicht explosionsgeschützt.
Nee also du brauchst dass das muss eben in einer bestimmten Art sein dass dass das da keinen Flug drin vorkommt das muss abgenommen sein,
wegen Knallgas und düzce Wetter du hast ja Wetter unter Tage so und wenn du jetzt knall Wetter hast,
oder wie das heißt ne wenn er also Grubengas sich da sammelt dann kann das ja zu einem Grubenunglück kommen und ich habe eigentlich auch überlegt ob ich nicht einfach in Zoom noch mit rein Schmuggel weil der macht ein bisschen bessere Aufnahmequalität,
habe wärmezahl überlegt bevor wir dann auch noch richtig mit dem größten Grubenunglück,
Kurzgeschichte schreiben der längste Podcast 8 Tage untertagebetrieb derrynane sind.
Beende ich auch geholt worden,
Podcast Kumpels ja.
Genau das wird also schön wir fahren auf Prosper ein untertage gucken uns da noch mal an,
und in wenigen Monaten endet ja der Kohlenbergbau in im Ruhrgebiet.
Ja das sagst du als dritte und Hannoveraner vielleicht nicht der also da das.
Umweltschutz erleichtert.
Das sagt sich so leicht daher ne das ist schon eine eine wichtige Epoche die diese Region die auch meine,
Heimat ist geprägt hat und das soll eben mit dem projekt Kohlenpott ja entsprechend,
dokumentiert festgehalten werden das ist der Podcast der rückwärts zählt.
Von 52 zur Folge 1 und jede Woche in sich mit dem Kohlenbergbau und der darum entstandenen Kultur in Deutschland auseinandersetzt und da freue ich mich mit dabei zu sein,
und dann aufblasbar einzufahren Post habe ich uns auch schon an Drohnen wie du gemacht.
Tanken können wir auch noch dieses re.
Tim wenn deine Mama auch langsam zu kurz zum lesen.
Essen hat geschrieben Anbu sag ich mal an wo entschuldigt sich für eine hässliche Karte das ist aber okay.
Anbu entschuldigt mal für die hässliche Schrift.
Und hat es ein Buch geschickt.
Ja ich seh schon wir Bürger als Sicherheitsrisiko.
Genau in dem er wir meint schon eigentlich alles gesagt wurde und das so einem release date von.
Ja findest du mich jetzt hier Musterung 77 ist das erschienen.
Wolf-dieter Narr und ja das wurde und zur Ansicht geschickt und nicht gelesen.
Und heißt es wäre einfach so rüber also herzlichen Dank an bro.
Anton Bruder am besteht ein wo da steht ein Bro was wahrscheinlich selber nicht so genau da sie.
Öffne karte zillow.
Ja davon von dem Celler dass das.
Sorry für die hässliche Karte.
Sag das Loch drauf.
Okay außerdem danken will welches Loch.
Achte drauf das Celler Loch.
Hier dass der eingetretene Hof da.
Ist heller lochis ist das Loch in den Mauern des Gefängnisses in Zelle was der Verfassungsschutz damals da rein gesprengt hat und meine einen aus,
klassischer Fall aus den 70er Jahren wo sich der schutzwürdig daneben benommen hat sie haben eine lange Liste.
Weiterhin danken wir,
alle oder allen oder ich danke Allah oder allen auch da Vista mach mir langsam Sorgen dass die dort ihre eigenen Namen,
unterschiedliche Schreibweisen unterziehen Christian Björn Hannover oder Ignaz der Gruppe.
Also Uwe und Ignaz Jens Toni besonders Katrin,
Sebastian und Constanze und Maximilian sei mein Dank hier an dieser Stelle,
eingegeben und ich wünsche euch ich wünsche mir dass ich euch danken kann damit dass wir nächste bei der nächsten Sendung schauen uns überlegen wen wir als nächsten Innenminister haben wollen
und ob ich nicht einfach den Verfassungsschutz übernehme und ordentlich abwickeln.
Sperrgut am besten daher als Innenminister.
Ja das wäre es ja denn wenn es da.
Als Innenminister Verfassungsschutz abwickeln.
Sack sparen mal wieder sparen sparen sparen wenn es nicht länger schnallen.
Bevor du noch auf verrückte Ideen kommst sagen wir mal tschüss.
Der Vater erreicht den Hof mit Müh und Not in seinen Armen das Kind war tot.